hello everyone I'm glad many of you
enjoyed my video on the Fischer game
analyzing that 21 minute endgame and a
lot of you thought it was very useful so
so I'm glad I will try to prepare and a
more educational video like that perhaps
over the weekend or something like that
but while we're waiting for the results
of around 3:00 or Doland chest classic I
decided to show you a game mchale towel
against tailed or get tesco it's a
suggestion from a subscriber the game
was played in 1963 at the game is called
in Soviet Russia Bishop takes pawn even
though the game was played in Hungary I
haven't really found the exact reason
why the game is called
in Soviet Russia Bishop takes pawn but
it has something to do with some
political wordplay maybe some of you
know the answer if you do do share in
the comments tell turkey Tesco is a
Romanian chess player
he became an international master in
1962 one year before this game was
played and he was awarded the honorary
Grandmaster title in 1986
so probably due to due to some
contributions he made the chess
community or it doesn't say why and in
1963 at the time this game was played at
a lorikeets s who was the Romanian
champion he also almost won the Romanian
Championship four times he placed second
four times and he got third place twice
so definitely a strong player and now he
faces Michael Tao tall has the white
pieces and let's see the game we have a
four by tau e v Knight to f3 knight c6
Bishop to b5 and a six
the Morphy defense Bishop to a4 Knight
to f6
may I I don't remember if I said that
this is the Royal opus the morphe morphe
defence variation of the real opus towel
castles Bishop to e7 rook to e1 b5
Bishop to b3 and here d Tesco goes for
d6 I don't know if I have shown any
Marshall Marshall attack games I think I
did
one video on the marshal attack if you
remember castling here is sort of like
inviting white to accept the marshal
attack inviting him to play C 3 and
after d5 we entered the marshal attack
but after Bishop to b3 d 6 by you Tesco
c3d Tesco castles H 3 now h6 d 4 rook to
e8 tonight B to d2 Bishop to f8 at night
to f1
transferring the knight to the Kings
side with the knight to g3 from there he
will be either able to jump to a 5 or h5
Bishop to d7 93 95 now with a tempo in
the light squared Bishop here
Bishop to C 2 and C 5 and this is still
all theory Tao he could play something
like d5 to close up the position but he
goes for b3
we have g6 now Bishop to e3 Knight to c6
d5 kicking the night away Knights day 7
and Queen to d2 Tallis preparing to
capture the h6 pawn and well you kind of
do have to defend this either by pushing
g5 or King to h7 came to h7 was played
by get a scoop and what would you play
here as white well there certainly are a
lot of options here you could maybe
maybe try to improve the position of
your rook rook a to see one rock the b1
depending on what you want to go for c4
is an idea but as the game say in Soviet
Russia Bishop takes pawn Tala plays
Bishop captures on c5 what's the idea
here you do have to capture the bishop
there isn't really a better move D
captures on c5 and Knight captures on e5
sotol gives up a piece for two central
pawns and that by itself is compensation
enough Knights the c8 buggy Tesco and
now f4 there seems to be this move
Knight captures on f7 nothing is
protecting this pawn but what would
happen if Tao captures it if not capped
sorry f4 was played but if Knight
captures on f7
would a temple on the Queen are now
Queen to e7
trapping the night and okay he does have
Knight to g5 with check and after H
characters c5 now and any move other
than capturing the point with the knight
would result in a massive Center for
white so after knife capture some d5 and
Queen captures Knights to be six and
black pretty much sold all of his
problems there there's no real advantage
here for white starter Knight to c8 tall
doesn't capture the f7 point he plays f4
he improves his center and locks that
knight on e5 Queen to e7 now see for
adding more protection to the d5 pawn
Bishop to g7 and now Knight to f3
not all is preparing to push be 5b
captures on c4 b captures on c4 and
Knight to d6 and it seems like Vitas who
is inviting towel to push me five now
and attack both of the Knights but he
does said that does have this Knight to
c4 would attempt on the Queen but told
us push me five we have Knight captures
on c4 and now Queen to c3 and here it
has two plays Bishop to b5 he protects
his Knight and gives up the f6 Knight
but Tull isn't interested in this knife
he plays rook a to d1 what would happen
after it captures on f6 and the Queen
captures on f6 you pretty much have to
go for the endgame here Queen captures
Bishop captures and after something like
rook a to C 1 since the bishop was
attacking your rook rook captures rook
captures anyone and there is there is
nothing here for tau black black is
better in the same game the bit the
bishop pair and the place on both sides
of the board how much a much better
sorry a much better position for black
so after Bishop to b5 rook a to D 1 by
tau
rook a to d8 and we have d6 now and here
Knight captures and e6 was played
allowing these pawns to stay here freely
if you play something like Queen of
Queen to f8 then e captures on f6
without a problem
so Knight capture some b6 e capture son
d6 and now Queen to b7
and Knight to e5 and okay Tao Tao got
back his piece and he does have this
beautifully test test D pawn and black
will have to play extremely correctly to
survive this night to be seven he wants
to exchange a pair of knights and here
it comes the only move that really gives
tall the advantage in the position top
plays Knight to h5 you can't capture
knight of course the bishop it means
this pawn and this dark square Bishop on
g7 is it's a valuable defensive piece so
you have to play Bishop to 88 not allow
the Knights to capture it
Queen to g3 now and now top towel piles
up on this g6 bond the knight is
attacking it the bishop is attacking it
and the Queen is attacking it
so Knight captures on e5 removing one of
the attackers but now F captures on e5
and now tal has these two past central
pawns and these pawns are our monsters
so Queen to d7
it's not easy to find a good move for
black your Queen d7 is a good move but
Knight to f4 now again piling up on the
g6 pawn Bishop captures on e5 and now
Bishop captures on g6 with check here
get tesco plays King - h8 what would
happen if he captures the bishop if F
captures and g6 then Queen captures on
g6 and after King to h8 rook captures on
e5 pretty simple rugged characters and
now Queen to f6 check attacking this
rook attacking this rook and after Queen
to g7 you simply captured the rook rook
blocks and now Queen the c7 offering to
exchange Queens and get your pawn all
the way to c7 a completely winning
position for white so after Bishop to g6
King to h8 was played in now top plays
Bishop captures on f7 he again offers
the bishop and here Bishop to d4 check
was played by Geetha school again what
happens if the bishop is captured if
Queen captures on f7 then Knight to g6
check King h7 and the simple knife
captures on e5
a winning position for white so after
Bishop to f7 Bishop to d4 check first
and again this is a very nice position
if foul play it's something like King to
H one here just to get out of the way
now Queen captures on f7 works for black
because Knight to g6 check and there is
no Bishop on e5 for this night to
capture so this would actually blunder
the game for tau so after Bishop to d4
top plays the only move that allows him
to keep his advantage that is rook
captures on d4 rook captures anyone with
check by a testicle Queen captures on e1
and Queen captures now on f7 we have
Queen to e5 with check and what you play
here Queen to g7 was played and now
simply Queen captures on c5 top could
have gone for something like Queen
captures and g7 would check and after
King captures night to e6 pinning for
King the king and the rook and after or
something like kinked f5 f6 not
capturing the rook but simply Knight
captures uncie uncie five and two being
two points up this is also winning for
white but you'll still have to work for
for your victory so after Queen to g7
thought simply played Queen captures on
c5 and now he's up two pawns he has a
beautiful pass pawn on d6 get ESCO tried
one more idea to play Bishop to c6
threatening checkmate on g2 and of
course if you play something like Queen
captures on c6 you get wink at first on
d4 would check and now of course you're
losing the game as white so after Bishop
to c6 robbed the d2 was played now
defending checkmate and in this position
dildora tesco the Romanian honorary
Grand Master resigned the game I mean he
could have gone for something but it's
actually winning by force for Tao this
Bishop is attacked on the on c6 and
after after Bishop to d7 nice to h5 and
the queen has no more squares on this
dark square dark diagonal only movies
qui
to a 1 check after Queen to a 1 check
into h2 you have to play something rook
to e8 and now rook to f2 Queen to e5
check you simply exchange exchange and
after knight Knight to f6 you're winning
the bishop on d7 if if Bishop was simply
d7 and the knight is preventing the rook
from stopping the pawn the rook can't
stop the phone from d5 or from a e8 as
the point is also protecting e so you'd
have to capture a knife captures and you
wrap a piece and upon are completely
winning this is just one of the
variations that shows how powerful the
position is so yeah after this rook to D
to move protecting checkmate get asked
to resign the game and this beautiful
game was created by Michael Tao as
Bishop did capture pawn on c5 in Soviet
Russia so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Haiti can therefore contribution to my
channel thanks a lot - really appreciate
it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I think all for
watching and I will see you soon
this time for real with a game from
London chest classic around three